Darby's are normally tough but this one
turned nasty as Majesty United player
Fred went to take a corner one city fan
makes what looks like a racist gesture
Nexen midfielder is hit by something
thrown from the crowd later officials
found a lighter on the pitch and
Manchester United reported that two
black players Fred and Jesse lingard had
been racially abused by City fans today
police arrested a 41 year old man he's
currently being questioned the Ariat
stadium can host around 55,000 fans but
it takes just a few of those to make
racist or discriminatory remarks to turn
what should be a beautiful game into a
very very ugly one Manchester City
reacted quickly saying the club operates
a zero-tolerance policy regarding
discrimination of any kind and anyone
found guilty of racial abuse will be
banned from the club for life but should
English footballing bodies follow the
international lead the European UEFA
League gave Bulgaria a 2-game Stadium
ban and a fine earlier this year after
their fans racially abused England
players should the same happen at home
does football have to look at itself and
think hang on a minute
should the club's themselves face
sanction and that is the issue really
now that needs addressing by all the
football and bodies by the primary by
the Football League by the Football
Association the time felt campaigns and
t-shirts and slogans has to stop at some
stage after turnaround since it's called
try it's okay if you've got any way in
your stadium of that nature you'll be
punished
last season sir a 66% rise in hate
crimes during matches in England like
racist abuse against man city's Raheem
Sterling and Arsenal player Pierre
Emerick Obama yang yes it could mean
that incidents are being better reported
but it is still evidence that there is a
problem it's much safer it's a much
better place to go and watch football
now than it was 30 40 years ago but
there's no doubt over the last two or
three years discrimination has been on
the rise as it has in the rest of
English society and we have to guard
against complacency thinking the
we can't go back to where we were to
15-20 years ago Manchester United went
on to win last night's game and Fred's
teammate Jesse lingard wrote not even
this idiot can ruin tonight's feeling it
may be the Derby but there is never ever
a reason to be racist Catarina vertices
Sky News Manchester